es war so in mir war schwindelig konnte
nicht mehr laufen mir war schlecht ich
musste kurz das war's also ich habe
wirklich gedacht fragt warum habe ich
nicht aufgepasst träume der sonne heute
mal ein bisschen was anderes ich war
letzte woche ziemlich viel unterwegs
unter anderem war ich auf der re publica
und der media convention das ist die
jährliche digitalen konferenz in berlin
die republik die konferenz wo man sich
am wenigsten bekommt wenn man so
der kamera alleine rumläuft und dieses
jahr war direkt neben der re publica die
telekom die tinte ist quasi die jüngere
schwester der re publica also eine
digital konferenz für jugendliche u 21
und obwohl ich als 31 jährige da nicht
mehr dazu gehöre durfte ich trotzdem bei
der team kann auf der bühne sitzen und
zwar als gast bei eva schulz falls das
tier das erste video sein sollte dass
die von mir sieht herzlich willkommen
neben solchen krieg normalerweise gibt
es hier science videos also ich rede
über wissenschaft heute geht es darum
warum ich das tue also was mich
motiviert was mich bewegt was so wichtig
darin ist also die metaebene des ganzen
und wenn ihr darüber auch mich und ich
bin besser kennen lernen möchte dann
macht es euch gemütlich eva kennt ihr
vielleicht von funk sie macht da das
politik format deutschland 3000
deutschland 3000 gibt es seit drei vier
wochen als podcast vielleicht kennt ihr
schon die videos auf facebook und
youtube jetzt haben wir eben vor ganz
kurzer zeit dieses lange format mal
gestartet wo ich coole leute treffen und
ausführlich mit ihm reden kann
diese folge war jetzt die erste live
aufzeichnung mit publikum und mit kamera
gleich deswegen zum beispiel große
bewunderung an mayer aus irgendeinem
grund mag zu chemie
[Applaus]
wir haben ungefähr eine stunde lang
geredet über chemie
für mich ist die chemie nicht nur die
böse und giftige chemie die gibt es auch
keine frage aber alles ist die chemie
wir alle bestehen ja aus molekülen und
selbst dieses gespräch ist ja chemie und
das will ich einfach gerne esse ich mich
gerne das bild konnte mir nur ein
bisschen erweitern aber auch über wie
das meer
ich habe mir gedacht vielleicht machen
wir das am besten indem wir mal so
typische klischees über
wissenschaftlerinnen chemikerinnen
auseinandernehmen
du bist jetzt mein premium
forschungsobjekt um zu gucken ob diese
vorurteile stimmen oder nicht das erste
ist wissenschaftlerinnen sind streber
und haben immer gute noten das ist eines
der größten missverständnisse überhaupt
werden glaubt mir ich kenne ja lauter
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
sind nicht sauer aber man braucht schon
so eine gewisse müdigkeit sag ich mal
man braucht er diese neugier und diesen
bis dann dran zu bleiben das unbedingt
verstehen zu wollen also wahrlich
klischees haben ja doch ein bisschen was
wahres wenn man nämlich wissenschaftler
in der popkultur beobachtet in filmen
und serien dann denkt man ok
wissenschaftler alle eine sehschwäche
weil die immer brillen tragen und keine
ahnung von mode
erstens ich habe eine sehschwäche ja ich
habe dann kontakt hinten drin
es ist ein bisschen was dran weil ich
würde schon sagen dass du in einem
chemie semester mehr leute findet die
auf denen es scheißegal ist wie sie
aussehen
man kann das ja auch positiv sehen ja
weil wie gesagt es geht hier nicht um
mich es geht hier um die wissenschaft
und deswegen findest du auch leute die
unmöglich aussehen mehr davon würde ich
schon sagen statistisch gesehen mehr
einem einer sehr guten freundin ist
melanie mit der ich schön schlau macht
das ist die grafikerin sie ist also eine
nicht naturwissenschaftlerin und die
lacht nicht manchmal aus und ich weiß
gar nicht warum also ab und zu sagen
hast du dein eigenes buch geblieben
weil da kriegt man nicht mit wenn man
das liest das heißt komisch alles
komisch dass tatsächlich wenn man deine
brille aufhat diese chemiker brille dann
ist alles chemie also ich habe wirklich
gedacht fragt warum aber chemie
unterricht aufgepasst das ist genau
grund warum ich das ganze mache denn
selbst wenn ich mit dem buch auf einer
lesung bin und dann im publikum frage
wer hier hat chemie in der schule
abgewählt dann meldet sich immer eine
ganze menge leute aber sie sind trotzdem
zu lesen bekommen sind trotzdem die erde
interessieren sich ja eigentlich doch
für chemie
sie wussten es nicht und auch ich ja
also ich war mir anfangs gar nicht so
sicher ob ich chemie studieren möchte
ich wollte ich habe mich für
verschiedene sachen interessiert aber
ich habe mich am ende dann doch für eine
naturwissenschaft entschieden weil ich
dachte wenn ich jetzt keine
naturwissenschaft studiere dann werde
ich weiß gar nichts mehr damit zu tun
haben und das traurige ist es stimmt ja
so ein bisschen ja also wann kriegt man
schon was von chemie mit im alltag ja
wenn irgendwo in einer chemiefabrik ist
ein unfall gegeben hat und auch das
möchte ich ändern mit diesen videos ich
möchte wissen schafft unser breiteren
menge zugänglich machen ich möchte nicht
das ist einfach ein wissen für studierte
eliten ist denn wissenschaft geht uns
alle an
was macht das mit dir wenn sich so ein
gestandener us-präsident hinstellt und
sagt den klimawandel gibt es gar nicht
ja also inzwischen bin ich ja ein
bisschen tot innen aber nein das ist das
ist mit teil der grund dafür warum ich
das warum ich irgendwann gesagt habe es
ist kein hobby mehr ich muss das machen
ich muss das beruflich machen ich muss
so klar das babor verlassen dafür wenn
aus der wissenschaft kommt neigt man
dazu zu denken kommunikations nur blabla
das was zählt sind zahlen und fakten und
das andere ist nur blabla das stimmt ja
überhaupt nicht wir sehen jetzt sehr
deutlich dass wenn ein us-präsident
irgendwie wie gefährlich so ein blabla
sein kann und dass zahlen und fakten er
auch nicht mehr als das gesehen werden
was sie sind sondern einfach verdreht
werden können ganz einfach ich krieg zum
großteil sehr positives und
konstruktives feedback aber unter den
negativen sachen ist eine sehr häufig
nämlich so was wie erhalte ich seine
youtube in oder dies nur moderatorin ist
ja gar keine echte wissenschaftlerin
gut das stimmt ich bin keine aktive
wissenschafterin mehr also ich bin nicht
mehr im labor aber eben weil ich nicht
mehr im labor bin kann ich jetzt mit
meiner arbeit einen ganz wichtigen teil
von wissenschaft machen der meiner
meinung nach zu kurz kommt das ist so
einer meiner großen frust punkte weil
ich finde die politik muss mehr in
sandwich schaffen muss mehr anreize
schaffen für forscherinnen und forscher
ihre arbeit zu vermitteln weil selbst
wenn ich jemand bin so wie ich damals
ich hab' ich habe daran spaß gehabt ich
habe im youtube-kanal gemacht ich konnte
das machen weil mein doktorvater so nett
war und gesagt hast du kannst das gerne
neben doktorarbeit machen
es gibt andere denen dann gesagt wird
hörbar zu deinen job ist es hier zu
forschen du sollst dir keine videos
machen du sollst dich mit leuten
sprechen du verschwindest deine zeit und
meine zeit und unser forschungsgeld und
das finde ich unmöglich weil die öffnet
forschung sollte öffentlich zugänglich
sein für alles sollte eigentlich viel
mehr wissenschaftskommunikatoren geben
dann hätten wir auch viel weniger auch
politische probleme wenn ich jetzt noch
ein denke was wir letztens hatten diese
jetzt gerade klimawandel impfen
impfpflicht organspende das sind alles
sachen wo wir uns viel zeit sparen
würden wenn die erkenntnisse aus der
wissenschaft der einfach klarer
ermittelt werden
dann hat mir eva noch ganz fiese
entweder oder frage gestellt ranga
yogeshwar oder harald lesch
da muss ich jetzt also wo also dass
diese fragen woher die sehen oder hören
können dazu kommen wir gleich drauf aber
vorher noch und meine allerletzte frage
was ich glaube was wir jetzt gemerkt
haben ist dass du tatsächlich immer die
chemikerin brille auf fast nicht im
echten leben aber so innerlich kannst du
die abstellen
die etwas warum sollte ich ist doch
traurig so auch so ich mache das alles
auch das buch und die videos weil mir
leid tut weil dir das passt
ich möchte euch teilhaben lassen an
diesem glück das ganze gespräch mit eva
gegen wie gesagt fast eine stunde lang
und wenn euch diese metaebene
interessiert dann schaut man in die
video beschreibung da habe ich euch den
link zum podcast gepackt da könnt ihr
euch die ganze volk in ruhe anhören auch
unterwegs
und überhaupt den podcast zu abonnieren
kann ich nur empfehlen jede woche kommen
neue gas und der podcast ist wirklich
gut gemacht also hört mal rein
an dieser stelle auch noch mal vielen
dank an die tinten und ihr team das sie
uns freundlicherweise die aufnahmen für
diese session zur verfügung gestellt
haben und wir sehen uns nächste woche
ganz regulär mit science bis dahin
bleibt sicher